another foreign policy crisis brewing on
joe biden's watch with a big assist from
nancy pelosi the speaker's trip to
taiwan setting off the chinese china's
military responding to pelosi's little
pow wow no offense liz warren
with a massive show of force right now
they are surrounding the island with
their largest military drill drills ever
in that area it includes jets
helicopters shooting live rounds and
firing off ballistic missiles so it
seems pelosi's active defiance and
biden's hands-off approach is tipping
the scale toward a major conflict
but remember it was that orange guy with
the happy twitter fingers who was the
real danger
the trump administration's reckless rash
decisions are no substitute for real
global leadership i sadly beseeched
president trump to apologize to the
american people
for that his disgraceful
dangerous and damaging behavior what the
president did
was
dangerous
clearly it takes preparation which the
president didn't make the president
abused his power for his own personal
political benefit at the expense of our
national security pot kettle black
while china is lighting up the skies our
geriatric commander-in-chief is taking
the aw shucks approach by refusing to
take a stand really any stand on nancy
going to taiwan in the first place
and it was good that she went we cannot
dictate and we will not dictate where
members of congress go members of
congress wait let me
let me let me finish when they go he
doesn't dictate it they go
now he can say if he thinks it was good
or not
i mean that's not how it works we have
said we have said consistently that the
speaker had a right to go um as speaker
of the house and a member of congress
yeah
even some in the media are saying joe
blew it politico pointing out how the
white house bungled the pelosi trip with
their muddled messaging and handed china
a big win
but rest assured joe has already
promised us that he has everything under
control
america is back
america is back
diplomacy is back at the center of our
foreign policy
beetlejuice so it sounds like the
situation calls for some leadership
maybe biden should just pick up the
phone
i know you said that there is not a
call scheduled with she is there a
reason why because president biden's
known him for
decades
he's got a lot of free time up there in
the residence this week he doesn't have
free time he's he's he can't just pick
up the phone and call been working all
the way through his illness quite
frankly peter so that's a little bit
insulting and um as for a call
it is
that someone who is isolating by
themselves you suggested he has a lot of
free time as if he's not doing anything
and you know that's not the case oh that
was nice
so harold uh in the green room uh we had
we were talking about this and you said
i just want to quote it correctly greg
you were right all along
trump never would have let this happen
on his watch they totally misunderstood
what he was trying to do and for that
i'm truly sorry
care to comment harold i don't recall
that but
you're a friend and you have great ears
and great hearing skills
uh uh we comment peter ducey does a good
job and is doing an even better job he's
always done a good job to keep keep up
the good work i think a couple things uh
and i'll be brief uh i think i i wish
the speaker had not gone um because i
don't know and for this reason i don't
know what set of objectives
strategic and serious objectives she
advanced by going and maybe some of that
comes out and i'd love to be corrected
on this
um i think the country we have to reset
our whole thinking around uh dagen and i
were talking about it yesterday that
the the new relationship and how we
think about china has to involve four
pillars
trade investments national security and
human rights
they are in here meaning we have to
think seriously about our own defense
budget going forward the next five 10 20
30 years
where we invest in cyber security and
other things that we have to protect
ourselves how we protect ourselves
against china
two there are a number of trade and
investment things that are happening
between our countries that we're going
to have to think about shareholder
rights versus uh a national security
interest and national security rights
the whole thing needs to be redone and
it's just unclear to me that this trip
advance any of those objectives and
finally we have to figure out how we
wean ourselves off of the supply chains
that are that are in china that are in
asia and for that matter china europe is
too dependent on gas products from
russia we're too dependent on supply
chains from china the chips act is
important i know we differ a little bit
on the chip sac digging but i think it's
critical to begin to help us ensure that
we build things here we produce things
here and when it comes to china a big
part of that plant and strategy ought to
be we counter them where we have to and
collaborate with them where we can we're
collaborating now with them in ukraine
but we have to counter them as it
relates to taiwan and other things what
are the consequences i'll go to you
emily uh to my right um
one of these consequences that people
are talking about is that it's pushing
china closer to russia do you think
that's the case do you think that that
that will be one of the consequences um
i do i think we're seeing that actively
and we saw that as ukraine being the
litmus test not only for their
relationship but also for that show of
would-be strength actual weakness from
our president um you know to your point
beijing produces 97
of us antibiotics so respectfully i
think we're way far past having our
future objective be to shore up the
supply chain and shore up our national
defense because it's a little too too
little too late in the last two years
alone secretary kirby just said this a
few minutes ago that the prc has doubled
the amount of aircraft that they've
flown over the center line that
separates china and taiwan earlier uh
former a.g whitaker talked about how he
prosecuted chinese for
intellectual property theft of feed corn
in iowa we've seen physical breaches
we've seen the amount of ip theft we've
talked about this on the business
network goes up to 660 billion dollars
per year so i think the amount of
infiltration that china has accomplished
specifically in the last two years
frighteningly and all of a sudden in the
last few days now their bark has become
or their bite has become almost as bad i
fear as their bark and i think the risk
that pelosi made uh by going over there
and showing such as like a fractured
democratic party and doing that all that
does is make us look weak well i think
we're a fractured country around it i
just their trip was not the right trip
or tommy but she didn't create this
problem we've had this problem brewing
for many many years as your comments
suggest no she made it much worse harold
stop it you know degan what's worse
calling uh the coronavirus the china
china virus or taunting them with a
shopping trip to taiwan um i i think
that the the taunting shopping trip to
taiwan that was pretty bad loaded
questions shopping i know you went
shopping
of course of course
uh biden silence on china on taiwan on
the origins of covet silent on the
epidemic of fentanyl poisoning is in
this country a million dead from covid
tens of thousands dying from fentanyl
poisonings every year and those lit you
were talking about those liberal
clatterbags on tv and in dc for more
than four years tried to undermine a
presidential campaign and then a
presidency you know the putin's puppet
uh um trump's an agent of russia
no basis in fact but now where where the
le where are the clatter bags bringing
the hammer down on biden's timidity
given the fact that his crackhead son
uh got handouts from china was
financially rewarded by china what a
good big daddy he is isn't he
uh
so that being said
i want to bring up
we need a
tiger for a president not a tit mouse
somebody with some temerity rather than
timidity a lot of t's a lot of anxious
anchors
a serious leader a true leader needs to
have a conversation with the american
people and prepare all of us for
economic battle
and i mean rally and ready all of us for
the sacrifices that we're all going to
have to make and that is a long-term
disruption in our way of life
because we're we need to get accustomed
to having less and a lot less no more
hand every time there's a small problem
oh here's a handout here's a check oh
you don't need to pay those college
loans you took out to go to that
college
the degree that's worth bat guano you
just throw money at people we cannot do
that anymore that money goes straight to
china to buy
garbage that they're well that our
company is producing but also this
semiconductor bill this is a bill that
enriches
and an already rich industry a lucrative
high margin business they did not need
that money
but we if we're going to cut off china
which we need to do
over time you cannot have handouts
because you wind up with venezuela like
inflation yeah
so jesse i think i saved the best for
last uh uh what we haven't brought up
here is paul pelosi
and i think you've been the um you
really have been in the forefront of
this explosive scandal
and how only one could it be that she
flew
yeah hear me out she flew to taiwan to
distract the public from what's really
going on with her husband so you've been
watching prime time i have every single
night for the last two weeks she timed
it perfectly she's a showboater
she did this to distract or maybe just
drum up some business prospects for paul
we don't really know she just wants to
cement her legacy to look like a china
hawk which she's not joe does look weak
he doesn't know what he's talking about
he doesn't even understand u.s policy
towards taiwan he's told what u.s policy
towards taiwan is and u.s policy towards
taiwan is we will defend that democrat
ally because of our trade relationship
they we design the chips they make the
chips there and then we use those chips
to make our economy move make the whole
world economy move if china moves on
taiwan
stock market goes down economy collapses
and you hit it right on the head talk
about sacrifices if they go into taiwan
this country is not prepared to realize
we're not going to have everything we
want so i don't think china wants to
risk war over taiwan they saw what
happened with russia and ukraine they're
a little anxious right now and we have
them surrounded we got japan south korea
we have the australians we've collapsed
that country in a heartbeat i think we
just have to manage china's decline
that's what we have to do make it
delicate be tactful i feared pelosi and
joe are not the most tactful people
especially the fact that joe's paid
by china his family yeah good point i
went on brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now